so let's go to an unhelpful advice uh
before that a fan named jay actually
sent in they found all the old yearbooks
at poway high school yeah you were hot
dude so that's yeah that's
that's 87 yeah and then here's 88 i
think your sophomore year you're on a
tennis team they did an article on you
yeah wow which was pretty cool well that
was in the article that was the yearbook
oh yeah like when people go um i'm not
athletic or i mean or you know i mean
but what exactly are you doing there it
says bobby backhand it says bobby lee
shows his latest dance moves while on
the tennis court
yeah but i was doing this a following
through with a backhand yeah you are
pretty because i didn't do a double i
didn't do a double hand back hand i
could do a single which is like the
fancy one yeah it's the fancy one yeah
you were really a good looking kid and
then this is uh junior year there we go
dude next to the cathy really good luck
yeah and then senior year
oh sweetie how cute yeah yeah i looked
like a you started getting a little
fatter then
that's the turn
[Laughter]
now it's going a little slower past them
but that that senior year though right
yeah it's from a different school so
i'll tell you what oh mount carmel okay
that's mont carmel right
so
mount carmel high school and poway high
school right we they they use the same
photography um studio oh remember i told
you so what they did was
they saw mine and mount carmel was 60
asian yeah right and in at poway high it
was like three percent so they just
assumed that my photo was in the wrong
section so they send it to bob carmel
and that's why i never went to mount
carmel but i'm in the mount carmelo
is that a true story
because i was just i never went to mount
carmel and i'm in their senior look up
their senior year photo that's you're
joking no that's a true story that's a
true story because look how many asians
are on here that's why they go there's
no way that this guy went to poway
that's [ __ ] crazy so racist that is
so racist it's still racist yeah look we
have one two three four five six
they just send the [ __ ] no but the other
then the freshman year that uh this one
no yeah what yeah go that one
right one girl
there's one it just doesn't seem as
asian right right yeah right go up and
down maybe yeah it's all white people
white yeah so that's why they made that
assumption and i remember now granted i
was sober so i was in aaa
right yeah so i got sober at the end of
my junior year my senior year now i'm
sober right and then the yearbooks come
out and i'm frantically looking at the
senior and now and then i make a call to
the administration and go um because i
remember taking the photo right let's
not let you know because you put a tie
on even i put a tie i did the whole
thing right i'm sober i'm going to wear
a sweater yeah you know i mean
no that's not yeah go back to the senior
one yeah yeah go back to the senior
look keep working i wear like a vest
this and that right yeah and i'm not in
it and i remember calling my sponsor
when they go oh we're so sorry but your
photo was sent to the other high school
right
and i remember i can't believe this is
my sponsor going i i i think i'm going
to relapse yeah because i did all the
things right you know what i mean he's a
common body it's just your senior year
right now i don't really care about like
it did hurt me back then no that's
that's hurtful yeah it did hurt me about
that yeah the way that makes me want to
cry because it's like very racist it's
so racist seriously and also there was
like only there was no apology from
their end right they were just telling
me the fact well you are asian and
they're you know they were like very
like
factual about it right and you know
because mount carmel's primary primarily
filipinos and other i mean yeah we've
got that
lagooda
look at this guy yeah
you know you look like alan laguna
so
we know so yeah so it was like
i mean look at it they just assumed yeah
is that insane yeah and and poway high
school is still today it doesn't look
like an american yearbook this is how
shisha is how racist they are yeah they
still won't put me in the hot the power
high school
walk of fame hall of fame hall of fame
really yeah they have a hall of fame
right no one in there has anything
remotely in my credits right right right
right one guy played like the violin in
some symphony you know i mean 20 years
ago and he got in to be fair tom delong
from blink 182 isn't on there either
yeah because tom delonge went to my
school they view my high school views
my kind of fame not real
it has